hey hey hey youtube.de mit fermino katze
steinecker hunde felsen 66 ist so macht
man das verstehen sie ein bisschen mehr
so lockerheit kann ich noch lernen ja
den straßenwahlkampf in zeiten der
pandemie ist eine einsame angelegenheit
das ist der ort ist die welt in ordnung
ein knallharter kampf um die wählergunst
in der provinz gott sei dank gibt es
dieses internet jetzt machen sie auch
bei youtube sachen was was stellen sie
bei youtube waren ich mach jetzt eine
kleine serie deswegen sicher ob
radfahrer flüsterer videos wie mache
jetzt hier so richtig fett ist youtube
tutorial wie man so ein fahrrad und
richtig so ein heißes teil wie das hier
wieder fit kriegt das ist schon starker
schlitten ja der fest
ok sollten wir mal angucken ja das wäre
cool ich würde es mit humor und sie sind
sich sind zu der spaßvogel bei dem größe
und wert robert habe er so der womanizer
ist der viel ein angebot hat aber dass
ich hab auch für viele ein angebot das
weiß ich sie kommen aus dem münsterland
aus münster westfalen ich bin auf dem
fahrrad geworden auch gezeugt das habe
ich meine eltern nachgefragt meine
mutter war im nachgang da ein bisschen
geredet aber engagiert ihr wieder gut
verstehen man kommt nicht so name ist
hermine hundefans termine hunde
feldstadt katze steifer als jahren aber
auch wirklich sein dass man hier habe
ich eine frage wie stark wird im
interesse des kanal des verbots
nachgegangen kann man mit einer grünen
regierung auf eine legalisierung weiter
hoffen 20 21 ok also hat sondern so ein
ganz normaler mann erst das war ja das
ist erstmal ein kann und wieso wurde
geschickt und sonntag 21 uhr naja
vielleicht sollten 22 bogen drin und
dann zuschlagen konnte üblicherweise
weil jack bauers man schnell check ups
die bremsen angeht ob da könne er ein
bisschen was gehen und das ist alles
einfacher wäre das eine montageständer
henke
das geht ja eigentlich auch ein weiteres
wissen sie schon also sie wollen ja
wiedergewählt werden wird sich
reparatur werden auch das wetter treibt
wenn ich noch nicht bewegen dann werde
ich mal wieder oder stört das dann eher
wenn man über politik reden also das
heißt also man verkauft sich als mensch
als fahrrad reparatur und sagt so ich
habe ein herz für fahrräder und das mit
der politik das spricht ja am besten gar
nicht mehr anders wir die leute wieder
verstören und eher im gegenteil die
finden das gut dass ich auch wirklich
noch mal mit die finger schmutzig machen
wenn ich daran gehabt
die finden das gut jetzt habe kann ich
mir ausgesucht so was hier mit pferden
da kann man natürlich als grüner gegen
schlecht gegen anstinken da wird der
chef das ist natürlich erstmal sonne
er ist natürlich frauen atmen schneller
wenn sie robert habeck sehen oder den
namen überhaupt hören manche männer auch
manche männer auch genau also es im
prinzip für alle fakten sagt man so bei
jungen leuten ja jetzt nicht so
altväterlich sondern so ein bisschen
auch wir haben sie mit jungen leuten zu
und auch so in die kamera und sagen so
hey dann ist es auch gut läuft in der
politik müsst ihr auch mal schmieren
damit sie in der politik auch mal gut
läuft das ist ja auch mal schmier die
kette oder frische der ehrlichkeit und
ich muss sagen hier der pressesprecher
der grün macht sich selber nach pass von
daher gesehen ist gedeckt von ganz oben
von stuttgart glauben sie an
außerirdische neid nicht wann ich mein
also von der beleuchtung her könnte man
denken sie ist ein signal irgendwie nach
oben in den himmel was soll denn das
ding hier an der ja völlig klar und das
ist auch sehr gut zur an dem die leute
also ich mache so einen dummen august um
die bürger gemacht hat so was sein dass
sie so ein bisschen so den schleifer
banner es ist auch immer gut wir mal
gucken wie viel abrufe wo sich denn das
hilfe so werden schon ich bin nicht so
der profi 88 hier aber ich habe 48
abrufe bei youtube jetzt schon mal acht
abrufen rausgeballert oder facebook
vielleicht auch noch mal mehr von diesem
auf ungefähr 15 hoch gebaut aber die
mutter nicht die kriege ich am
marktplatz uns auch nicht auch noch
genau so zwei minuten was gemacht dafür
und und dann was ich für meinen fans ein
bisschen
das sind mutter vom internet wahlkampf
ach ja aber hierzu auch sie haben das
auch schön so aufnahme hallo
dies ist die automatische and cut von
oliver welke und der heute show
leider ist das video schon vorbei ihr
könnt den kanal allerdings gerne
abonnieren und ein weiteres video
anschauen vielen dank so müsse jetzt für
immer reich